I wish it wasn't just the dark times
bringing us together but it is friends
like you that make those dark times
worth having people step back
we got this word team fates compelled me
to bring you together
how did you do that I'm Supergirl Yahoo
no weed
then you can keep out girlis steel just
you watch Scarlet speedster
hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
they just dropped like a big teaser for
Supergirl season 2 flash season 3 all
the stuff is going to be happening with
the CW DC TV shows next season the
reason there's not new footage is
because all the actors are on hiatus
right now Stephen Amell for instance is
promoting Ninja Turtles that's coming
out in June so the actors don't go back
to work til like the end of June early
July they'll start shooting the next
season will probably see official
trailers for all the different series by
the end of the summer maybe around
comic-con time so what's happening right
now is they're presenting all this
material to advertisers saying what some
of their big signpost plans are like
look this is definitely coming in the
distance we might not have all the
details worked out yet but this is
happening so what they talked about is a
four-night crossover which I feel like
we all kind of predicted what's going to
happen you bring Supergirl onto the same
network as three other DC Comics shows
that are already connected of course
they're going to do a big for an eye
crossover so what the schedule is going
to be next season is Supergirl will
still be on Monday night's flash will
still be on Tuesday's arrow Wednesday's
legends of tomorrow on Thursdays I don't
know what they're going to do with
legends because it was only 16 episodes
last season unless they change the
episode count they might do eight in the
fall eight in the spring but it sounds
like though all the airing concurrently
starting in the fall you know like arrow
and flash normally starts that first
week in October that's probably when
they're coming back they didn't announce
an official premiere date that'll
probably happen towards the end of the
summer they haven't started shooting yet
so like once they start shooting and
they get a couple episodes in the can
they'll make the announcement on the
premiere date they haven't really
clarified any details about how
Supergirl is going to work with all the
other shows because technically she's in
a different universe so what might end
up happening because we know Cisco on
the flash so I'm going to be talking
about flash and arrow things going on
this season so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't been watching the flash
Cisco now has the ability to open
portals to other Earth's he's not really
great with it they kind of explained in
the last episode of the flash that he
doesn't fully understand his powers so
it's not like you could tell him hey
Cisco opened a portal to bizarro earth
and he'd be able to do it he's not quite
there yet
what they might do is find a way to
create a more stable connection with
supergirls earth unless they want to do
some crazy earth-shattering thing where
they want to combine her earth with
earth one I don't know that they're
going to do that because the logic is
pretty outlandish but I've learned over
time that the flash TV show is just
fully committed to being as weird and
amazing as possible so I'm not going to
make too many assumptions about what
they're going to do with supergirls
earth in the multiverse but remember
Superman exists on her earth so if they
do want to combine earths then they have
to find a way to explain Superman on
earth 1 because as far as we know Batman
Superman those people don't exist yet on
our earth but because they did confirm
for and I cross over and we have a
Kryptonian we have Supergirl I think
they can totally do Justice Society now
I don't think they'd ever be able to use
the term Justice League just because of
the movie things that are happening but
remember Geoff Johns is one of the new
Kevin Feige zuv DC Warner Brothers films
so a lot of times Geoff Johns in the
past has been the person that they go to
when they're like hey can we do this
character on the TV shows is that ok we
want to change it just a little bit so
he gives approval for a lot of that
stuff so now that he's in charge of all
of DC's films it might be a little bit
easier for the TV shows to do movie type
things so I know everybody always
wonders when a big comic book character
is killed off on the TV shows is that
because they're doing them in the movies
I think that'll be less of a thing in
the future for everybody who's not like
a marquee character a lot of you have
already started asking me about the
thanagarians in this war that they're
doing on legends of tomorrow are they
going to be the big villains of the
super flare Oh legends crossover next
year I don't know that for sure but that
does sound like a pretty easy slam-dunk
so if you're not caught up on legends of
tomorrow careful for spoilers for that
TV show right now they've threatened
that the thanagarians are going to
attack and that's the whole reason the
time masters were helping Vandal Savage
because Vandal Savage was going to help
protect the earth from this invading
thanagarian force so the heroes on
Legends called [ __ ] on that and
basically destroy the time masters plan
so now the thanagarians are free to
attack earth so that's probably what's
going to be happening on that show in
season two but that also might spill
over into the other shows so think of it
as a TV show version of infinity war
where you just have like this massive
war that threatens all these different
Earth's in the multiverse we can talk a
little bit more about that after the
legends of tomorrow finale which is
tonight so what's probably going to
happen is is that video will post
tomorrow just because there's a whole
bunch of TV trailers for next season so
I'm going to be doing a Star Trek
trailer later tonight be sure to
subscribe to get that there's a new Star
Trek TV show being made by Bryan Fuller
it's going to air on their digital
service so if that sounds confusing CBS
is kind of making their own version of
Hulu to air shows on it's like a
subscription service the new Star Trek
series is going to be like the flagship
show on that so you'll be able to watch
new Star Trek episodes made by the same
person that makes Hannibal there's like
so many awesome Bryan Fuller shows I'm
so excited about this and I'll talk more
about that when I post that trailer
video later tonight so there's like a
whole bunch of stuff happening this week
I'll try to hit it all during the videos
that I post so I'm really excited about
TV and I'm really happy that Jeff Jones
is now getting the credit that he
deserves
he should be in charge of all of DC's
films he's the guy that when all the
executives at DC want to do a character
or producer comes in and it's like hey
I'm looking for a superhero film what
about this this character is free Jeff
Jones is the guy that will go in and
explain that character to all these
executives who may or may not have read
comics that's kind of the thing that
Kevin Feige used to do back in the early
x-men days at Fox like he was involved
with a lot of those early superhero
films then they were like hey you know a
lot about comics and you're really good
at producing films why don't you be in
charge of all this
thus Marvel's phase one is born is
incredibly successful and now look at
where they are now so Geoff Johns is not
Kevin Feige
he's a character guy he understands
characters so he'll be working with a
lot of the other film people just to
make sure that they do the characters
right and that's really the most
important thing but he'll have like the
highest level of authority so like he
could veto a Zack Snyder decision if you
wanted to just for reference while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for last night's episode
of arrow and flash I also had like a
special you know my gold play button in
it so if you watch that video you'll see
me you know thank everybody for the gold
play button it's really cool and thank
you by the way you guys are amazing and
you can click here to learn about what's
going on with Gotham court of owls
they're doing a lot of Batman comic book
things in season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight